all right now we have a story of an
artist who uses
the ocean as a museum
over the past 15 years jason
decary's taylor has been transforming
seafloors into public art spaces the
sculptor environmentalist and underwater
photographers projects explore our
relationship to the natural world all
around us and underneath of us
for our series pushing the limits
elizabeth palmer met decary's taylor at
his workshop in england to explore the
message behind his underwater art
15 feet down just off the coast of
grenada stands a ring of concrete
children
nearby a lone man sits at a typewriter
welcome to the world's first underwater
sculpture park the creation of british
artist jason decary's tailor
traditional
artworks were often quite
about the dangers of the sea and
battling battling the elements the
elements and man versus nature
um and so i'm trying to sort of uh
change that in a way and show how
incredibly fragile it is how incredibly
uh finely balanced the project began
with decares taylor casting living
grenadians in plaster after a hurricane
had destroyed many of the island's coral
reefs
he wondered if underwater sculptures
based on the cast could lure divers and
tourists away from the reefs that had
survived maybe if i created something
that was a distraction or
you know a way to attract them to an
area that was barren or that had been
impacted by the hurricane
then it you know that would give
the the reefs that were growing
better conditions to grow
yes
the sculptures made of non-polluting
concrete kept growing and changing too
ocean creatures moved in plants
fish
and coral are slowly turning them into
artificial reefs
that first marine sculpture park has led
to others from mexico to the maldives
what goes through your mind when you
swim around your installations and see
them fusing with nature initially
they're all just barren stretches of
sand underwater with very little marine
life
but when i go and see them now you know
there's turtles there's soft corals
there's
you know hard corals there's massive
shoals of fish
octopus this
massive center of life
decare's tailor is much in demand in his
workshop just outside london are casts
from more than a dozen marine
installations
which have grown more political to
reflect his passion for the environment
and his worry about humanity's
precarious future
i think this is probably one of the most
obvious sculptures that i've made
and it was part of the recent
installation in cyprus
uh and it
yeah i think you know it's pretty
self-evident about generations yes
carrying us
one of his recent installations sits on
australia's great barrier reef
she's called the siren wired to show the
ocean warming around the coral
and 20 feet underwater off the coast of
cyprus a new project has just opened
human forms in an underwater forest
that's already drawing marine creatures
i suppose part of the message as as your
sculptures get encrusted with living
creatures is this this ocean is full of
life
and it will regenerate given the chance
definitely i think there is a yeah a
sort of a positive narrative that people
take away when they visit the works that
i hope that it it reminds them that you
know we are nature you know we're part
of the environment we're you know we're
dependent on each other
for our ultimate survival it's this
symbiotic relationship
for cbs mornings i'm elizabeth palmer in
london
nicely done
liz palmer don't you think it's very
calming don't you feel calmer yeah
absolutely beautiful work and even more
beautiful over time you know that song
everything's better when it's wetter you
know it